the k68 is the latest mechanical
keyboard from corsair and it's meant for
the slightly more budget-conscious pc
gamer it's one of the few mechanical
keyboards from a big manufacturer with a
retail price at or under a hundred bucks
[Music]
we previously reviewed Logitech sub $100
offering in the g4 13 so check that out
after this video but back to the K 68
it's essentially an iteration on the
Corsair strafe as it shares a very
similar design in price point but the K
68 makes key improvements keystrokes are
much quieter due to the rubber like
casing that lines of the mechanical
switches it doesn't affect the
functionality of the keyboard and the
linear non tactile Cherry MX red
mechanical switches still provide a
smooth and responsive feel note that
there aren't any options for other
switch types and the clumsy folk out
there like myself will be at ease with
the k68 as it's waterproof up to IP 32
standards this basically means that
spilled water that comes down on the
keyboard up to a 15 degree angle won't
damage the keyboard thanks to the rubber
casing underneath the key caps and there
are vents at the bottom to let out any
liquid that drops into it another
significant improvement is the addition
of dedicated media keys play pause stop
and volume control have their own
buttons and makes handling music apps
much easier than using alternate modes
on a function row but why would you
spend all this money on a keyboard
anyway well mechanical switches not only
make gaming more comfortable but the
responsiveness is an advantage in
competitive games especially if you come
from a standard squishy membrane
keyboard this was most apparent during
my time with battlefield 1 and Counter
Strike global Offensive split-second
reactions matter in these fast-paced
first-person shooters being able to hit
the ground prone or swap weapons at a
moment's notice can make all the
difference in firefights for battlefield
one constantly strafing left and right
is an important tactic and Counter
Strike and the bouncing responsiveness
of the keys allowed me to pull this off
with ease since mechanical switches have
a distinct actuation point well know
exactly when a key is being pressed and
key strokes will register without
failure I personally like the square
blocky design of the keyboard and
appreciate its simplicity and that
textured spacebar is pretty sweet
but if
you're looking for a bit more style the
k68 probably won't excite you it only
features red backlighting but you can
customize the lighting behavior in the
corsair q software although it's not the
most user-friendly peripheral software
out there the packaging also comes with
a detachable plastic palm rest which can
improve comfort but it's a bit curious
as to why the k68 doesn't come with a
key cap puller which is essential for
getting underneath the keys for cleaning
overall there's a lot to like about the
corsair k68 since it doesn't really do
anything wrong and iterates on a
previous keyboard that was already great
will you want to switch to the k68 if
you already have a mechanical keyboard
probably not hundred bucks is a hundred
bucks but it's more affordable than
other corsair keyboards like the case 70
inkay 95 it's still a big purchase
decision but if you want to jump to a
mechanical keyboard with cherry MX Reds
it doesn't get much better than the k68
I know you'll like this video so give us
a thumbs up and if you want more reviews
and discussions of gaming tech subscribe
to our channel here at GameSpot thanks
for watching
[Music]